das fasziniert mich so an korea
die geschichte und die daraus
entstandene mentalität der leute
sie sind vor allen dingen auf die
kollektive arbeit ausgerichtet und
vollbringen dabei wirklich dinge die man
einfach nicht für möglichkeiten zum
beispiel der bau des 15 kilometer langer
stau ihren am tor
es gibt so viele wunderschöne stellen
nordkorea
[Musik]
immer wieder was neues finden wird und
jeder sache eigentlich in der innung
dann 2014 habe ich dann eben die erste
reise dorthin durchgeführt mit 25 leuten
das ist immer dann an den bussen mit
angebracht dann natürlich dass wir auch
immer ein paar worte daneben haben dann
das wichtigste wort beim us open
wir haben uns recht und weisen hier 34
jahren hier also 36
das ist die militär parade die mit einer
großen aufmerksamkeit und anteilnahme
der bevölkerung stattgefunden hat also
ich kann nur sagen diese einheit von
bevölkerung partei und armee die so
offensichtlich geworden
frieden frieden frieden braucht die welt
und alles angriff keine option offen